Game of Thrones Season 8 episode 4
starts with the living morning the dead
Daenerys cries over Jorah a loyal friend
and protector Sansa cries over Theon and
puts a stark pin on his Greyjoy Armour
Theon never felt accepted by either
family in life but in death he's a
Greyjoy and Stark
Berek edie Lyanna kono and thousands of
others died in the long night including
some hundred thousand zombies who were
all once men women and children John
gives a speech and says everyone set
aside their differences to fight
together
but soon division and suspicion set in
and a new war takes shape after all the
death of the living celebrate life with
food drink and sex in that order
Daenerys speaks with Gendry the bastard
son of the old King Robert Baratheon all
the Baratheon's are dead now so Danny
decides to legitimize Gendry to
illegally remove his bastardy she makes
him Gendry Baratheon Lord of storms end
this is a common strategy in Game of
Thrones you give someone a position of
power that they owe to you and you've
made yourself a powerful ally
so Daenerys calls this a clever move but
legitimizing Gendry is risky he's the
son of a king
so Gendry or his children could
potentially make a claim on the throne
like a hundred years ago the Targaryen
s-- legitimized the bastard black fires
which led to a series of rebellions that
lasted for generations
Gendry might not rebel but any of his
descendants could the Lord of storms end
rules the Stormlands one of the Seven
Kingdoms of Westeros so Gendry is now
one of the most powerful politicians on
the continent which is crazy because as
Gendry says he doesn't know how to be a
lord he hardly knows how to use a fork
this is also a reminder that the Seven
Kingdoms exist Westeros is a feudal
society ruled by a hierarchy of Lords
and in early seasons the story focused
on the families who ruled each Kingdom
but now they seem irrelevant
no one even seems to know who rules each
Kingdom the Tyrion and Davos talked
about the Lord of Light the fire-god
were
shipped by Melisandre it seems as though
the Lord helped win the war against the
White Walkers his magic lit the trenches
and the air axe and guided meltus and
ayah at the night King it said that his
magic resurrected John and Barrack gave
Daenerys her dragons gave the Hound of
vision and had some great destiny
planned for them all but now devil says
the Lord of Light [ __ ] off with no
explanation so what was the magic and
destiny stuff all about tyrion says
thinking about this won't make you happy
which is like a meta message to the
audience telling us that the gods and
magic and prophecies in the story won't
be explained so don't think about it
Tyrion speaks with bran and bran says
that his wheelchair is based on a
specific historical wheelchair as the
three-eyed raven bran can see all of the
past and present it would be nice if he
revealed something useful like Cersei
and Euron's military movements but
instead brand talks about wheelchairs he
says he mostly lives in the past and
that he doesn't want anymore
becoming a magic wheelchair encyclopedia
has caused bran to lose his humanity
tyrion says that brands knowledge would
make him a good ruler and Varys later
says that the best ruler might be
someone who doesn't want to rule and
bran doesn't want so if the show wants
to be really surprising they could end
with bran on the throne strangely bran
has been a favorite on bedding sites for
months now maybe someone knows something
and like how else will brand story end
if he won't rule Winterfell and won't be
a tree man maybe he'll be king tormund
talks up Jon saying he's a great leader
because Jon is strong makes allies
writes dragons and doesn't afraid of
anything and Daenerys is upset because
she's a strong leader and Dragon writer
and she's been doing it for six seasons
she sacrificed half her armies friends
and a dragon saving the north and yet
she's still not getting the love and
loyalty that she needs this is similar
to when Danny's brother Viserys was
jealous of Dany for the loyalty she got
in season one
Viserys reacted with rash angry violence
which led to his death
and the show might be hinting at a
similar fate for Daenerys tormund says
that Dragon Riders are either kings or
madmen John is framed as a king and an
heiress as a madman and yeah there's
also a coffee cup in the shot which is
either a production mistake or the
smartest product placement ever Tyrion
Jaime and Brienne play Tyrians drinking
game from season one where you have to
guess truths about each other
Tyrion guesses that Brienne is a virgin
and she gets uncomfortable and leaves
Jaime goes after her breaking the heart
of poor torment he has a massive crush
on Priyan but a serving girl comes to
cheer him up pod the rod picks up two
girls he's made a reputation for himself
The Hound speaks with Sansa last time
they saw each other Sansa was a scared
naive girl and Hound was fleeing battle
he had offered to take Sansa with him
but she refused and ended up with
Littlefinger and Ramsay Sansa says that
her experiences made her the person she
is now she learned from some of the
worst people in Westeros and their
manipulative methods and their cruelty
have rubbed off on Sansa she smiles
about having Ramsay torn apart by dogs
just as Ramsay smiled when he had people
killed by dogs and Sansa scheming this
episode to undermine Daenerys is totally
Littlefinger's style while everyone else
has fun together
Arya is alone training Gendry comes and
asks her to marry him
to be the lady of storms end but ayah
says she's not a lady
that's not her which is a reference to
season 1 iron ever wanted to marry a
lord and have 10 kids in a castle so she
turns Kendra down this is similar to
when Kendra's father Robert loved is
aunt
Leanna Leanna was a rebellious
adventurous girl like aya and Robert was
a Baratheon warrior with a hammer like
Gendry Liana didn't love Robert back she
ran off with Rhaegar and had John
instead and so Robert started the war
that took down the Targaryen x' tyrion
says this episode that the last 20 years
of war traces back to Robert and Leanna
so hopefully Kendra takes rejection
better than his father did Jamie comes
to Brienne's room and uses the classic
it's too hot in here for clothes smooth
there's been sexual tension with these
guys since season 3 and now they finally
consummate their love
they're both awkward and shy this is
Brian's first time and it's Jamie's
first time with anyone other than Cersei
Jaime and Brienne have never had healthy
sexual relationships before and Jamie
ultimately he can't handle it when he
hears the Daenerys is closing in on
Cersei Jamie leaves Brienne and rides
south
Brienne begs him to stay says he's a
good man and that he doesn't need Cersei
but Jamie feels defined by his crimes
he crippled bran killed his cousin and
thread and Riverrun all to be with
Cersei Cersei represents Jaime's
failures and flaws and he feels that he
can't escape her or change the hateful
man that he really is so has Jaime's
Redemption arc failed
Jaime's story isn't as simple as a bad
guy becoming a good guy Oh author George
Martin says that Jaime's arc explores
the limits of Redemption whether it's
even possible to be forgiven for crimes
so horrible Brienne believes in Jaime
but Jamie doesn't believe in himself
maybe he'll return to Cersei and to her
hateful ways or maybe this is about
confronting Cersei maybe Jaime will
redeem himself by facing his evil twin
he's darker half the books hint that
Jaime might kill Cersei but he might die
in the process Jaime and Cersei believe
that they'll die together this is all so
awful for Brienne one of the defining
moments in a backstory was being mocked
and betrayed by boys who pretended to
Lika now she's suddenly dumped by the
first man she ever made love with
Brienne has won respect as a knight but
will she ever get love maybe she'll
follow Jaime south and play a role in
the final confrontations Jon and
Daenerys get their [ __ ] on until they
remember that Daenerys is Jon's aunt
John's real name is Aegon Targaryen and
he has a better claim on the throne than
she does so Danny's worried that people
will want him
rule Westeros instead of her she saw how
people loved him as a leader and even if
John refuses the throne he could still
be used against Danny
so she begs him to keep his identity
sacred but John says he has to tell his
family the truth Ned Stark kept the
secret of John's parents all his life
but now John is determined to reveal the
secret even though it could destroy his
relationship with Danny and his family
the war against Cersei is planned
apparently only half of the unsullied
Dothraki and Northman died last episode
it had looked like most everyone died
but apparently the zombie apocalypse
wasn't so apocalyptic after all Cersei
has the golden company twenty thousand
mercenary soldiers Daenerys has the
north and the Vale and now she also has
the Iron Islands and Dorne
thanks to Yara and a new Dornish Prince
so Daenerys is in a strong position she
just needs to find a way to remove
Cersei without killing innocent people
in King's Landing Cersei is using
civilians as a mate shield Tyrion and
Jon suggest putting the city under siege
and starving the people until they rise
up against Cersei which is a pretty bad
plan in season six so she blew up the
Pope she murdered hundreds of innocent
people including the faith the beloved
Tyrells and her own uncle and everybody
including hot pie knows she did it
Cersei has no claim on the throne she
hates the people and the people hate her
so surely if the people were gonna rise
up they would have done it already and
sure maybe starving the people will
motivate them but that defeats the whole
purpose of taking the city without
hurting innocents a much better solution
to the Cersei problem is standing right
there
Arya is a highly-trained faceless
assassin just last season she
infiltrated the twins war Walder Frey's
skin and wiped out an entire house
surely she could sneak in and kill
Cersei and next to aya is bran the guy
who knows everything and can scout with
Ravens also present is Davos who
smuggled Tyrion into the red cape last
season these characters defeated the
apocalypse last episode surely together
they could use their skills to kill
Circe safely and if all else fails they
could just attack King's Landing
normally with soldiers and try to
minimize casualties just like every
other battle Daenerys has fought this
expectation the Daenerys has to capture
the capital gently is totally
unreasonable it's a plot contrivance to
make Denny choose between two extremes
will she find a peaceful solution or
will she burn them all like a father
before her Sansa and i--i confront John
and say that they don't trust Daenerys
they don't want their home and their
family subject to a foreign dragon queen
and Sansa doesn't want John to march
south and there's a history of Starks
going south and not coming back but John
says he's not a stock he reveals the
truth that he's a Targaryen
so this separates John from the Starks
is he still part of the family
John was Aya's favorite brother growing
up because they were both misfits ah a
tomboy and John a bastard but now it
turns out that John wasn't a bastard and
he wasn't her brother he's a Targaryen
cousin this could distance John from his
sisters though the scene cuts off so we
don't get to see their reactions John
makes his sister's swear to keep the
sacred swearing in front of a hot tree
has religious significance but Sansa
soon breaks her vow and tells Tyrion
because Sansa wants John on the throne
instead of Daenerys Tyrion tells Varys
and the scheming begins so John's secret
and Sansa's oath breaking threatens to
divide Daenerys John and the Starks ayuh
rides south with the Hound and she says
that she won't go back recently I had
declared that she was a stark of
Winterfell but now it seems she's
rejecting her family and home maybe
partly because of John's revelation hyah
says she has unfinished business which
probably means killing Cersei and the
mountain the last two names on her death
list but if eius exceeds what happens
next
like can are you live without a family
the Starks say that the pack survives
but the lone wolf dies
the hound also has unfinished business
he wants to kill his brother the
mountain and he suggested before that he
and I you could do it together he
mentions how aya once left him for dead
when he was hurt maybe this time I will
mercy kill her friend Braun turns up at
Winterfell and threatens Tyrion and
Jaime he was sent north by Cersei who
offered him a castle if he kills her
brothers but Tyrion offers Bronn a
better Castle Highgarden
the capital of the rach it's a
ridiculously rich prize for a sell sword
like Bronn but bran argues that every
great house was founded by some
cutthroat and he's not wrong when the
Tyrells took Highgarden they were just
opportunistic stewards and House
Lannister is said to have been founded
by land the clever
who used a combination of trickery sex
and butter to take Casterly Rock
so Tyrion promises to give bran
Highgarden no promise that he probably
can't keep like even if Daenerys wins
her war why would she agree to give one
of the most important castles in
Westeros to the cutthroat who threatened
Tyrion and shot her dragon last season
bran walks away satisfied with this
empty promise even though his complaint
in the first place is that all he's got
from the Lannisters is empty promises
the whole bran arc this season seems
kind of pointless so why is it in here
in a recent interview George Martin said
that sometimes TV networks demand more
of a popular character even when they're
not relevant to the story and the video
implies that he's talking about bran so
maybe that's why bran so prominent this
season Jon farewells torment he and the
wildlings are going back beyond the wall
and John sends ghost along with them
this loyal direwolf survived a cavalry
charge on the dead last episode but now
Jon gives him away without so much as a
pat this represents Jon breaking away
from his stark identity or maybe it just
represents that the wolves are annoying
to film Tommen says that Jon would be
happier beyond the wall that he's got
the real North in him some of John's
only moments of real happiness were
beyond the wall with yogurt Jon says he
wishes he could go north with tormund
and Tommen says you never know there are
theories about
John's story ending in the north either
as a night's watchman or a white Walker
II person or just some sad duty so he
can get back to brooding in the snow
which is what John was always good at
maybe in the end John will return north
and ghosts will get the Pats he deserves
John farewells Sam and Gilly Gilly is
pregnant with their kid and she says
they'll name him after John Thrones
journalist Johanna Robinson writes that
this is similar to the end of The Lord
of the Rings the hero's best friends
named Sam gets a happy ending he falls
in love with a woman named after a
flower and they named their kid after
the hero but the hero Frodo is damaged
he never quite heals from his wounds and
so he passes on to a distant realm maybe
like Frodo John will have a bittersweet
ending beyond the wall author George
Martin has said that the ending of
Thrones will be similar to Lord of the
Rings
Tyrion tells Varys about John's
Targaryen identity and Varys thinks that
John would be a better ruler than
Daenerys because he's a good leader and
cuz he's a man which the Westerosi
prefer it's pretty ridiculous that Varys
turns against Danny so suddenly he
supported her for at least four seasons
and for good reason
Dany has spent her whole story learning
to be a queen but now Varys dumps Dany
for the first person he sees with
Targaryen blood and a penis Varys says
he's worried about Daenerys state of
mind and there is a history of Targaryen
'he's going mad and violent like Danny's
father the Mad King but Varys didn't
care when Danny burned and crucified
innocent people in Mereen so why turn
against her now Varys says his goal is
to bring peace to Westeros but by
jumping from one ruler to another so
many times Varys has contributed to
chaos and war of course the obvious
solution here is for John and Daenerys
to get married to combine their claims
but Varys dismisses the marriage idea
the story just won't let John and Danny
have such a simple happy ending
the Targaryen flate wretches Dragonstone
and suddenly you're on 360 noscopes that
dragon Rhaegar with scorpion bolts from
ships that he'd hidden behind a rock he
demolishes Danny's fleet captures Masson
die and kills the dragon so in one scene
this [ __ ] discount Jack Sparrow does
as much damage to Daenerys as the night
king managed in the entire long night
and Daenerys should have seen this
coming
she's been sneak attacked by iran's
fleet before her dragons have been shot
with scorpions before and this all
happens at Dragonstone right on Circe's
doorstep one of the advantages of
dragons is that you can see threats from
miles away so how did she not see iran's
11 ships Daenerys suffers a terrible
loss and it doesn't feel earned or
meaningful it feels like a stupid
implausible [ __ ] at least it's finally
confirmed that Varys is a mermaid an old
theory from the books
Daenerys wants to retaliate by attacking
King's Landing and Varys warns her again
that that would kill thousands of
innocents Varys looks Danny in the eye
and says she's making a mistake
because last season Faris promised that
he would warn Dany if he loses faith in
her and Danny had promised that she
would burn Varys if he betrays her it's
starting to look pretty likely that
that'll happen
Daenerys says it's her destiny to free
the world from tyrants maybe the way
she'll fulfill that is by destroying the
Iron Throne a symbol of tyranny Varys is
worried by Danny's talk of destiny
people like Melisandre have done
terrible fiery things in the name of
destiny but it also seems like destiny
saved everyone's ass in the long night
whether for good or for evil
Danny's destiny surely involves fire
Daenerys takes Tyrians advice and faces
Cersei at King's Landing
realistically Cersei would just use all
this weaponry to mode of them on sight
but that wouldn't make for interesting
drama so kybun comes out to talk like
the mouth of Sauron but he won't listen
to Tyrians attempts at compromise so
Tyrion approaches Cersei directly saying
that Cersei is not a monster that she
surrender to save herself and her unborn
child Cersei has lied and betrayed
Tyrion over and over but Tyrion still
wants to believe that he can save his
sister Cersei is moved by his words but
she's too proud and too hateful to back
down
Cersei executes smiths and I and it's
tragic that Masson die dies wearing
chains
Daenerys freed Masson died from slavery
but Cersei takes Masson dies freedom as
well as her life grey worm is
heartbroken and furious Masson died was
everything to him but no one is angrier
than Daenerys Cersei has killed Danny's
closest friend and killed Rhaegar one of
her children has mother of dragons she's
just lost Jorah and Hoffer armies last
episode and her allies plot against her
behind her back Daenerys has waited
seven seasons to take the throne and now
she's ready to burn anything in her way
miss and I his last word his true chorus
which means fire so will Daenerys burn
King's Landing in a fury like a father
the Mad King will Daenerys become the
tyrant that she came to destroy and what
will her allies do will Varys undermine
Daenerys will Tyrion stay loyal will Jon
have to put down his love it would be a
depressing ending if seven seasons of
Daenerys rise to power ends in her going
crazy and getting killed but Danny's
actress has hinted that she's not happy
with the ending next episode will be
bloody and fiery and dark this season of
Game of Thrones is full of dragons and
armies and magic but sometimes the most
powerful force in the story is
information the secret of Jon's
Targaryen identity could end to Danny's
quest for the throne and Varys has
always known the power of secrets
secrets are worth more than silver or
SAP oz waar is named in the books
Faris's motivations run much deeper than
just helping the realm he and Illyrio
have personal stakes in a complex
conspiracy involving Targaryen the
golden company and
dangerous secrets you can start the book
series for free today by signing up for
a trial with audible members get a book
each month and if you cancel you keep
the books you can read in the car or the
gym or while you sit on your boat taking
potshots at dragons sign up at
audible.com slash ASX thanks for
watching
we're holding live streams right after
each episode of Thrones and patrons can
watch past live streams thanks to attach
altar notes for the artwork and thanks
to the patrons including Sam London of
house of Emily first of his name lord of
Union Square and protector of the realm
thanks to Peter Meehan Maria Isabel
Mendoza Sigma nine to seven Caitlin a
Wilson Melina curtain and camicazi
Cheers